toi be j'ai besoin de temps aucun mur je
t'en prie construit un petit peu moins
forts pourquoi il ya quelqu'un qui dort
mais non mais du risque de me faire peur
en criant comme ça je suis dans le
jardin en train de travailler
tranquillement tout est calme reposant
ensoleillé qui arrive en hurlant je ne
me rends pas j'ai seulement quelque
chose d'important à te demander
ce qu'elle achetait coup trop vieux
monsieur du snav et moi avons décidé
d'unir nos deux talents artistiques pour
créer une oeuvre commune une sorte de
recherche d'un vrac il dit et en quoi
puis-je vous être utile à tous les deux
et bien voilà cette oeuvre sera à une
oeuvre souffle émouvante à soupe les
vôtres ou alors il m'a chargé de
récupérer les matériaux avais tu ne la
trouvais aucun arcil vos confrères gens
j'en ai plein mais j'ai peur de me
tromper pour écoute casimir je pense que
les enfants vont pouvoir aider les
enfants venez vite casimir a besoin de
vous je vide ton sac casimir les enfants
vous savez ce que c'est qu'un corps
solide
oui il ya de la consistance qui est
ferme et un corps liquide qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un bolide c'est un corps qui
coule alors oui oui mais pour ma
sculpture il faut donc des solides à
soupe la wii et vous pouvez peut-être
nous donner quelques exemples de solides
le banc du bois le caillou
la barre de fer fabien et des exemples
de corps liquide
non
l'eau du vin la bière d'un jour laisse
enfin il y a également de l'essence
casimir il ya également les solides
souple dire ceux là peuvent se tordent
où se déformer voilà c'est ce qui
l'animé voudrais que dans ce tas
d'objets nous mettions de côté les
solides souple les séparer alors qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est la fille seule
alors c'est encore comme un solide duo
solide solide souple regarder la ficelle
ouais c'est pas rigide oui ça fait mis
dehors ah bon alors je le mène au
maintien des milles à l'est aussi parce
que c'est
c'est solide où celui ci au plein
soleil ou prévenir je mets de côté bon
ceci
oui qu'est-ce que c'est une planche
d'angoissé solide
ceci est ici oui c'est une nappe alors
c'est ça ce torse et mouthe c'est donc
sous portois casimir qantas culture à
celle de monsieur du snav ceci est ce
que c'est
un rouleau à pâtisserie dont ils
manquent d'ailleurs une poignée alors
c'est solide ou solide souple solide oui
très solide même donc de côté qui ceci
non c'est pas une chambre à air c'est un
pneu
il est alors
c'est solide sous la pression des
meilleurs pour moi je ne la donne
ceci
[Musique]
dit ce libre solide souple c'est du film
127 heures durant le temps doit donc
rentable et solide
souple c'est de la mousse et enfin
or ces bourses à une bourse est solide
ou solide souple et solide soutien
casimir aulas vous remercie mes enfants
je pense que vous avez validé casimir
c'est vraiment gentil mamaev mois et
fait gagner beaucoup de temps à la
casinière je file monsieur du sondage
matin julie je lis qu'est ce qui a
quasiment dit à la bbc non je ne suis
pas blessé mais ce sens du snop
demandeur qui est malade on ne le
supporte plus alors ce n'est pas trop
grave et si c'est pas grave il est
complètement fou mais si nous n'en
voyons casimir tu sais bien que monsieur
du snav et toi vous n'avez pas les mêmes
idées alors c'est naturel qui est des
différends entre vous à c'est vrai nous
sommes bras différent raconte moi plutôt
ce qu'il perde fait merrion jusqu'au mot
alors je ne comprends pas nous avions
décidé de faire ensemble une oeuvre
d'art oui parce que c'est une très bonne
idée break seulement il nous fait rien
il ment donne des ordres c'est tout un
faisceau si tu restes là va chercher des
clous comme cela
ça n'est pas très interne aimerait lui
pendant ce temps là il reste allongé sur
fort et amis et en verre de grenadine à
la main nature maison il est monstrueux
quand je ne le fais pas dire hun sen
lors les coûts de casimir dit luis tu ne
veux pas refusent de travailler mais je
te parle
pas parce qu'il a pris mon gloubi boulga
de quatre heures ils le gardent il l'a
caché et il ne me rendra quand la
sculpture sera terminé
alors si c'est comme ça je vais m'en
occuper moi même et tu vas voir je vais
les peut leur apporter ton gloubiboulga
casimir kazemi casimir au nom non
monsieur du snob casimir n'est pas là
mais d'autres sont là à qui vous
pourriez dire bonjour monsieur dix n'ont
pas pardonné léonard je te salue je vous
salue de même monsieur du stand mais
j'apporte le gloubiboulga à casimir oui
je voulais le faire une farce mais je
crois qu'il l'a très mal pris pour poser
là il le trouvera en rendant sur la
table
bon mais je te salue un bientôt vous
partie des gens oui parce que j'ai
commencé une statue solide souple et
j'oserais la finir alors plus tard
monsieur duchesneau ou encore un moment
voyez vous je m'ennuie un peu et
j'aimerais bien entendre encore une fois
toutes ces bêtises que vous avez fait
parce que vous êtes si ce nom bon je
vais te le dire mais ne dis pas que ce
sont des bêtises plus jamais d'accord
alors musique
[Musique]
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au concours j'ai jouer à saute
d'un point avec un chef eskimos je suis
13 tonnes chaque jour je code un gros
oeuf d'autruche amant petit déjeuner
j'ai chanté un opéra dans la rue à
tombouctou trouver les trésors cas dans
un musée du pétrole les gens s'arrachent
mais autographes on m'a reconnu dans un
heureux de mon quartier je
suis un champion dé la sculpture
[Musique]
je
fait les chefs présents peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de ma belle
soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve c'est qu'ils me l'a
dit il très snob comme moi il colle un
gros oeuf d'autruche à son petit
déjeuner
il sait parler ce trust of avec un
accent anglais
moi j'y arrive beaucoup mieux avec la
sam à payer
j'ai lu talent c'était
de toute marge sous la célébrité jeu
suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
je
fait des chefs-d'oeuvre vente peinture
je suis le plus grand le plus beau le
plus fort mais il m'arrive quelquefois
de faire un rêve un peu fou je m'appelle
monsieur durand et j'ai les mêmes
jeanne supplice mort alors je colle un
petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tous des
primaires
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien je vois ma canne mon
chapeau et mon costume italien
ch redevient ce mot alors je colle un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon petit
déjeuner
[Musique]
j'ai dû soit là et vous chantez part du
marché ou d'infirmer léger mais il n'y a
pas deux mais qui tiennent donné tu es
moi mais ma chère amie l'a
jamais je n'ai vu julie dans une
pareille colère
pour monsieur du snob
par prendre pour autant pas propre à
prendre mais enfin quand fait julie elle
devrait me rapporter mon gloubiboulga
qu'est ce que c'est que ça pour que le
roi on les enfants ne la laissez vos
jouets cassés ou derrière moi prenez là
derrière le club il ya un monstre là bas
vous avez vu
casimir que ce passage
du jeu à cache cache non non pas du tout
franchement il ya un monstre à fond avec
une grosse tête de l'epad yeux une
grande propose un monde mais moussa il
alors au fond du jardin regarde au quasi
mais un effectif battue tu as raison
elle restait bien cacher les enfants
restent bien caché je vais je vais
essayer de voir ce que c'est fort
prudent oui attends je vais je vais
prendre un petit détour par ici vous
derrière moi je m'occupe des enfants
restés là cachez-vous
attention car si vous ne bougez pas
non mais
messieurs du snap mais c'est vous
les enfants dépêchez vous le danger est
passé non content j'ai vu des vite venez
vite
ah bon
mais ce n'est pas mon style mafieux de
ce matin des masses et desmond dans
votre eau dernière sculpture est
vraiment réussi une essayer de vous
tirer de là
à l'épaule dès maintenant
kiki et julie hoyaux julie commencement
c'est julie qui vous a fait ça oui
vraiment ce
qu'est ce qu'il est arrivé ils sont
devenus complètement pour
compliquer mans merci
à
voir